(applauding)
Salman: As I just introduced what
Khan Academy is most known for
is this library of videos
that I started producing
almost five, six years ago now.
Before I go any further, let me just
show you all a little bit of a mix
of what the videos actually look like
and then we can go a
little deeper from there.
So the hypotenuse is now going to be five.
These animals fossils are only
found in this area of South America
a nice, clean band here
and this part of Africa.
We can integrate over the surface in
the notation usually is a capital sigma.
National Assembly they create
the committee of public safety
which sounds like a very nice committee.
Notice this is an aldehyde
and it's an alcohol
start differentiating it to
affect or, and memory cells.
A galaxy, hey there's another galaxy.
Oh look there's another galaxy.
For dollars is there 30 million
plus the 20 million dollars
from the American manufacturer
if this does not blow your
mind then you have no emotion.
(audience laughing)
You know the videos
there's now 2,200 of them.
That's kind of what I want to
do until I get a hit by a bus
or hopefully it won't be for a while.
We're doing a lot more than that,I
mean the videos are reaching ...
Actually now, on the order of about
two million unique users a month.
We've had almost 45 million video views
they are being watched 2
to 300,000 times a day.
Before I go any deeper, I actually just
gave a talk at TED down in Long Beach
a couple weeks ago, I don't want
this to be a repetition of that talk.
I want this to kind of be a part two.
But before I go any further,
I want to get a sense
just so I know how much background
and depth I need to give.
How many of you all seen that talk?
Okay, good.
How many of you all have been to the site?
Because I want to know how much
background, okay very good, very good.
What I want to focus on today is
kind of going a little bit deeper.
I will give a background about what
we're doing beyond the video portion.
Now that it isn't just me.
We are actually kind of a
team now, we're at six people.
(audience laughing)
Some of the questions
that I think have surfaced
is we've gotten a little bit more popular
and we started to enter into domains,
but frankly I never
thought we would enter.
Especially into the classroom itself.
Before I do that,I want to give you all
a little bit of a thought experiment.
Imagine if we're in a juggling class
and I'm your juggling instructor.
This week we are going to
learn to juggle oranges.
I give you all your orange juggling
kits, I give you all each four oranges
and I give you all a
lecture on juggling oranges.
I say practice and in a week I will
assess your orange juggling ability.
You practice and a week later I come
back with my clipboard and I say juggle.
You try the best you can to juggle
and different three oranges,
four oranges, all the rest and I say,
"You can't juggle four oranges at all."
"Three oranges, barely can
keep the oranges in the air"
"for more than a few seconds."
You are a 70% orange juggler,
you are a D orange juggler.
I place that label on your forehead.
I put it in your permanent
record making it all
but impossible for you to go
in an elite juggling school.
(audience laughing)
Despite those deficiencies that
you clearly have in your abilities,
there's the state mandated a juggling
curriculum that we have to follow
and there's a calendar that specifies
how we have to move forward.
We have this kind of
assembly line and so I say,
"Well give me back the oranges. The
next lesson here are some knives."
(audience laughing)
As crazy as that might appear to be
that's exactly what's happening
in our classrooms right now.
It might not be as physically dangerous
but it is just as mentally dangerous.
We have students they take
an exam, they get 10% wrong,
20% wrong, 30% wrong, you
can even fail an exam.
Regardless of the fact that we've
identified those deficiencies,
we know that the student
doesn't know those concepts,
we have to move on to the next
concept, we have this assembly line.
That the only thing were using
the test for is to put labels
on peoples foreheads to
separate them, to track them.
Though we know there's
weaknesses we push them forward
and we're pretty much ensuring that at
some future point they'r going to fail.
We're pretty much ensuring
that motivated kids,
even if they have awesome
teachers at some point
those gaps are going to come back and
they're not going to be able to perform
once they get to some
more advanced mathematics.
Now that we've gotten a funding ...
just so you know a little bit of
the story how all of this happened.
I was literally making videos in
my closet for about five years.
Then about a year ago Google
brought me over to their campus
and I thought it was just like
a lot of the Google engineers,
as parents they were using these videos
for their children and all of that.
But they brought me in to a
conference room and they said,
"Sal, what would you do
with two million dollars?"
(audience laughing)
I said, "Is this an education context?
Or is just a broader question?"
(audience laughing)
There are very different answers.
That happened and a little bit
later, I mean this is like last year,
I was still in the closet.
(audience laughing)
I get a call from Larry Cohen,
who's Bill Gates chief of staff,
and says, "I don't know if you realize
this but Bill Gates likes your videos."
"He watches them, he uses it with his
kids, and he would like to support you."
"Do you have some time to
meet him in the near future?"
I said, "I think I can move
around my calendar a little bit."
(audience laughing)
I think I can push back a few of
the video recordings here or there.
But you fast forward to
October of this year,
we got funding from the Bill
and Melinda Gates Foundation.
We got the funding from Google.
In a sense it allowed me
to come out of the closet.
What we're now trying to do
there is take these videos
to their natural conclusion, and
address that juggling mastery problem.
What we're doing, if you go
to the site it's all free,
it's a not for profit, not
trying to sell anything.
You can start at 1 + 1 = 2 and we'll
give you as many problems as you need.
As you get 10 in a row,
you can keep advancing to more
and more advanced concepts.
The paradigm here is don't
move on to a next concept
until you master the one you already know.
As an organization what we're trying to do
and it seems like there's already a little
bit, we're getting the traction here
and we'll talk later and to talk about
why we think we're getting that traction.
What we're trying to do is enable
anyone, anywhere in the world for free
to get one an education but
when we say an education,
to get an education that really
is a mastery based education.
One that really ensures that
someone understands the basics
before they move forward and they
can do it all at their own pace.
I want to be clear, this is actually ...
We'll talk more about this in
the second half of the talk.
This isn't a new idea,
it's actually nothing that Khan
Academy doing is fundamentally new.
Doing videos either online
or even on TV or whatever,
it's not a new idea when the
radio was first invented,
when TV was first invented,
people thought it was going
to revolutionize education.
Put the best teachers, broadcast
them, it never happened.
Even when the internet kind of came out,
they thought that was going to be
the killer [happen] for the internet.
When the PC was first invented,
they thought this was the first time
we can give people self-pace learning
but it never got traction.
In the second half of my talk
I'd like to think a little bit about
maybe why we're getting a traction.
It's a super important question
for us as an organization
because we don't want to lose
whatever that secret sauce might be.
The other interesting
thing that's happened
and I talk a lot more about
this in the other TED talk,
and is actually a big surprise to me,
is that our software and video start
to get adapted in the classroom.
I mentioned the previous talk
that it happened early on
even before we got funding or anything.
I started getting letters
from teachers who's saying
that they were using just the
videos to flip the education model.
They were now assigning
the videos for a lecture,
they were assigning
the videos for homework
and instead of doing a
lecture in the classroom,
they were actually allowing their
students to interact with each other
in doing problems.
Just with that simple technology,
just the on demand video
they were actually able
to kind of personalize
and make the actual classroom
experience interactive.
Now with this kind of self-paced
mastery base learning software,
we were approached by the Los Altos
School District not to far from here,
"What would you do with a classroom?"
We said, "Well we would let every
student work at their own pace."
The teachers role would
be, they have a dashboard,
they would have all of the data
and only intervene on the
students that are stuck.
So you could do a very
focused intervention
and be armed with the right data to do it.
Or even better get a student
who's already proficient in that
to intervene on that student
and then you get all the benefits
of learning something even deeper
when you yourself are the teacher.
They decided to do it.
In Los Altos we have two fifth grade
classes and two seventh grade classes
and they're using this
as their core curriculum.
What I want to emphasize here
and it's not always made clear
is when I talk about this to
people, a lot of people will say,
"Oh this awesome."
Self-pace learning, mastery based,
differentiate in instruction
but there is a crowd that starts
to get a little suspicious.
They start saying well, "This sounds
like you're automating things"
"but it sounds like it's very robotic."
"It sounds like kids in front of a
computer just doing exercises all day,"
"listening to videos, not
interacting with each other."
"It sounds like you're
marginalizing the teacher."
"It sounds your deskilling the teacher,"
"that you're making them just
do what the computers can't."
What I want to emphasize
here is the exact opposite.
What we're seeing in those
classrooms in Los Altos,
is we're seeing every
moment of that teachers time
is spent interacting with
her students, being a mentor.
These students are getting one on one
with the teacher multiple times a week.
When I was in school I was lucky
to get that even a few times,
and even in your whole career.
Multiple times a week.
They aren't doing this at the
expense of project based learning
or investigations.
What this is allowing the teacher
to do, it liberates the classroom.
So now that they can do more
of the project based learning,
they can do more of the investigations.
These classrooms in Los Altos, there
is more of that creative activity,
more of this interaction, more of
this experimenting with the world
than you would see in any other classroom.
So for the first time because
we have this technology
it's not an either or proposition.
You have this kind of camps
of mathematical instruction.
Do you do kind of the traditional,
do a lot of problems, lecture and
see a lot of traditional problems?
Or do you do the project based
learning where you investigate things?
Our answer is now we can do both.
Even better, even on the instruction
itself there's these debates
between old Math and
new Math, how you to it?
The value when you have on
demand video, you can do both.
You can actually expose the
students to every possible way
that there is to learn Mathematics.
In the same classroom, you have
one kid doing third grade Math
and you have one kid doing
Algebra, and that's great.
The student doing the third grade Math
needs to be doing the third grade Math.
Here she needs to fill out those gaps,
and the student who's doing the
Algebra should be able to run forward
and do the Algebra.
Then some people say, "Oh this is bad."
"Already the smart kids
have the advantage"
"and the slow kids they already
have every disadvantage."
"Now you're making the spread even wider."
But what they don't realize
is in these same classes
it's becoming impossible to
figure out over a longer term
who those smart kids are
and who the slower kids are.
Because even though one kid is working
on third grade Math for a little while,
once he or she has getting those [cuts]
and we see it over and over again,
they're able to race ahead.
Then three weeks later they passed
up the kid who is in Algebra.
All of this kind of
labels start to disappear.
The other thing that we're kind of
thinking about as we grow our organization
and we really want to make sure we have
a good hold on it is why is it working,
why is it resonating?
These ideas heave existed forever on
demand videos, self-paced learning.
The real data points we've been getting
obviously we've had the user growth,
we've had the traction,
Bill Gates uses it.
(audience laughing)
For me personally the real data points
has just been the user testimonies,
the letters that we get
and actually the first feedback just
turned into a little bit of a one liner
was for my cousins ...
Their very first feedback when I
put 20 or 30 videos up for them,
they said that they preferred
me on YouTube than in person.
(audience laughing)
We just keep getting them and I
think there's a common theme here
and I'll just read a couple real quick.
There's one, "My eldest kid is
dancing around in my room here"
"because she is so excited
that she finally found someone"
"that teaches like this."
I feel uncomfortable, I don't like doing
the self praise, I mean I don't ...
But what's cool here is that
this girl she wasn't just happy.
When she learned something,
when she was actually able
to connect with the material
it wasn't like "Oh I'm
going to nail the exam."
She felt the visceral desire to dance.
(audience laughing)
(applauding)
There's all sorts of ... this is a letter
and this takes me back to my college
days when I didn't have a girlfriend.
I don't know if these boys at
Bellarmine can relate to this comment.
(audience laughing)
This is a comment from a college student,
"There's always so much else that
a student has on their mind."
"What is a pretty girl
looking like today?"
"What was the professor like
when they were a student?"
"Should I talk to the
pretty girl after class?"
"Will I include last weekends
event in a book about my life?"
"That the slightest drifting of focus"
"quickly turns into a fruitless two
hours spent daydreaming or unconscious."
"Please continue what you are doing."
(audience laughing)
(applauding)
It was actually a much longer
letter that I had to reduct,
it wasn't appropriate for this audience.
(audience laughing)
This is what I got two days ago,
"I've taken Calculus 1 three times."
"The first time I didn't pass the class,"
"the second time I had to drop the class."
"My girlfriend's mom
told me about the site,"
"she heard about it in a
conference, I checked it out."
"I began supplementing, proceeding and
sometimes even replacing my lectures"
"with your videos and I received
an 84% on my first midterm."
This is the third time he's taking it.
"I almost cried, I was so happy."
When I first try, it's 84 that's
a good score, why's he crying?
"Especially because the
class average was a 47%."
(applauding)
"Now the second midterm is coming up,"
"I feel confident enough to say that I
will most likely get an A in the class."
"Since my major depends
on me passing the class,"
"I want to thank you for helping
me save my college career."
It's pretty a mind blowing stuff
and I think you can imagine why I quit
my day job as a hedge fund manager.
Wasn't quite as much psychic reward.
(applauding)
I think the take away here is that ...
and this is the learning that we never
want to forget as an organization
is that, people come to the Khan
Academy wanting to just fill in the gap.
They have an exam, they
want to pass an exam,
but once they actually experience
what it's like to learn,
it doesn't matter who they are.
It could be the student
who's about to drop out.
Once they actually experience
it for the first time in life
they get addicted.
It's a natural high, it's something that
we innately, all humans want to have.
That's something as an organization,
we don't want to ever forget.
That if we can form these
human bonds using technology,
that's what's actually going
to allow us to succeed.
I want to leave you with
one quick little story
from one of the Los Altos classrooms last
week that kind of hits the point home.
There was a reporter
from NBC doing a story
on what we're doing in that classroom.
And there's a little fifth grader
and she's doing trigonometry
and actually all of the
boys are very envious of her
because she has the most badges and
points and all of that other things.
The reporter sits down
next to her and says,
"Do you think this is fifth grade Math?"
Then the little girl has a mischievous
smile and she looks at the reporter
and she goes, "No, I
think it's sixth grade."
(audience laughing)
Thank you.
(applauding)